in this video we're going to think a
little bit about parallel lines parallel
parallel lines and other lines that
intersect the parallel lines and we call
those transversal so first let's think
about what a parallel or what parallel
lines are so one definition we could use
and I think that'll work well for the
purposes of this video are there are two
lines that sit in the same plane when I
talk about a plane I'm talking about a
you can imagine a flat two-dimensional
surface like this screen the screen is a
plane so two lines that sit in a plane
that never intersect
so this line I'll try my best to draw it
and imagine the line just keeps going in
that direction in that direction and let
me do an another one in a different
color and this line right here are
parallel they will never intersect if
you assume that I drew it straight
enough and that they're going in the
exact same direction they will never
intersect and so if you think about what
types of lines are not parallel
well this green line and this pink line
are not parallel
they clearly intersect at some point so
these two guys are parallel right over
here and sometimes it's specified
sometimes people will draw an arrow
going in the same direction to show that
those two lines are parallel if there
are multiple parallel lines they might
do two arrows and two arrows or whatever
but you just have to say okay these
lines will never intersect and what we
want to think about is what happens when
these parallel lines are intersected by
a third line by a third line let me draw
the third line here so a third line like
this a third line like that and we call
that right there this third line that
intersects the parallel lines we call a
transversal transversal line because it
transverses the two parallel lines now
whenever you have a transversal crossing
parallel lines you have an interesting
relationship between the angles form now
this shows up on a lot of standardized
tests it's kind of a core type of
geometry problem so it's a good thing to
really get clear on our heads so the
first thing to realize is
if these lines are parallel we're going
to assume these lines are parallel then
we have corresponding angles are going
to be the same what I mean about by
corresponding angles are I guess you
could think there's four angles that get
formed when this purple line or this
magenta line intersects this yellow line
you have this angle up here you have
this angle up here that I've specified
in green you have let me do another one
in orange you have this angle right here
in orange you have this angle right here
in this other shade of green and then
you have this angle right here right
there that I've made in that bluish
purplish color so those are the four
angles so we talked about corresponding
angles that's we're talking about for
example this top right angle in green up
here that corresponds to this top right
angle in what I could drew it in that
same green right over here these two
angles are corresponding these two are
corresponding angles and they're going
to be equal these are equal angles if
this is how may make up a number if this
is 70 degrees then this angle right here
is also going to be 70 degrees and if
you just think about it or if you even
play with toothpicks or something and
you keep changing the direction of this
transversal line you look it you'll see
that it actually looks like they should
always be equal if I were to take let me
draw two other parallel lines
let me show maybe a more extreme example
so if I have two other parallel lines
like that and then let me make a
transversal that goes that forms a
smaller say it goes even it's kind of
even a smaller angle here you see that
this angle right here looks the same as
that angle those are corresponding
angles and they will be equivalent from
this perspective is kind of the top
right angle and each intersection is the
same now the same is true of the other
corresponding angles this angle right
here in this example it's the top left
angle will be the same as the top left
angle right over here this bottom left
angle this bottom left angle will be the
same down here if this right
here 70 degrees then this down here will
also be 70 degrees and then finally of
course this angle and this angle will
also be the same so corresponding angles
let me write these these are
corresponding angles are congruent
corresponding corresponding angles
angles are equal and that and that are
corresponding that and that that and
that and that and that now the next set
of equal angles to realize are the
sometimes they're called vertical angles
sometimes they're called opposite angles
but if you take this angle right here
the angle that is vertical to it or is
opposite is you go right across the
point of intersection is this angle
right here and that is going to be the
same thing so we could say opposite I
like opposite because it's not always in
the vertical direction sometimes it's in
the horizontal direction but sometimes
referred to as vertical angles opposite
or vertical angles are also equal so
that's 70 degrees then this is also 70
degrees and if this is 70 degrees then
this right here is also 70 degrees so
it's interesting if that 70 degrees and
that's 70 degrees and if this is 70
degrees and that is also 70 degrees so
no matter what this is this will also be
the same thing because this is the same
as that that is the same as that now the
last one that you need a I guess kind of
realize are this the relationship
between this orange angle and this green
angle right there and you can see you
can see that when you take when you add
up the angles you go halfway around the
circle right if you if you start here
you do the green angle then you do the
orange angle you go halfway around the
circle and that'll give you get you to
180 degrees so these this green and
orange angle have to add up to 180
degrees or they are supplementary and
we've done other videos on supplementary
but you just have to realize they form
the same line or a half circle so
right here 70 degrees then this orange
angle right here is 110 degrees because
they add up to 180 now if this character
right here is 110 degrees what do we
know about this character right here
well this character is opposite or
vertical to the 110 degrees so it's also
110 degrees we also know since this
angle corresponds with this angle this
angle will also be 110 degrees or we
could have said that look because this
is 70 and this guy is supplementary
these guys have to add up to 180 so you
could have gotten it that way and you
could also figure out that since this is
110 this is the corresponding angle it
is also going to be 110 or you could
have said this is opposite to that so
they're equal or you could have said you
could have said that this is
supplementary with that angle so 70 plus
110 have to be 180 or you could have
said 70 Plus this angle are 180 so you
could there's a bunch of ways to come to
to figure out which angle is which in
the next video I'm just going to do a
bunch of examples just to show that if
you know one of these angles you can
really figure out all of the angles